libertarianism is all about individual
liberty and it should never be defined
by the terms liberal or conservative and
communism is no good that's right big
swing and a miss yeah and what's the
word for when a few clerics are in
charge religious oligarchy holy
i can remember things
i guess first we do the written exam and
then we do the personality evaluation
which i feel like i'm going to nail
because people always say but he's got a
great personality
okay quiz me
okay what does it mean when an officer
calls in a 35-42 assault and battery the
way i remember that i picture 35 assault
shakers and 42 batteries great what is
the criminal code for arson arson is
533. you know i remember that i picture
533 salt shakers and batteries lighting
a building on fire oh i'm nervous
babe look at me you were going to pass
this to us and you're going to become a
cop so this test will determine whether
you have the right personality profile
to be a police officer just to make sure
the machine is working
is your name andy
i don't know how to answer that
simple yes or no well everyone calls me
andy but my full name is andrew i think
so
no
wait
yes
let's move on scenario a high school
aged child asked to hold your service
revolver what do you do yes
i gave it to him when i was a kid i
always wanted to hold a cop's gun to
make that dream come true for another
kid well
that's what being cop's all about
scenario you pull a car over for
speeding you find out that it's your
father how do you handle the situation
well first i would be like
dad
you're alive
what the hell also do you know where my
catcher's mitt is
hello chief fugleberg hey that's your
buddy andy dwight
such a shame oh no
did he fail his test it's weird he got
100 on his written test first guy in
history to do it but he failed his
personality examination he's a sweet kid
just doesn't have what it takes to be a
cop
oh andy too bad he's certainly something
of a genius
we could use his brains on the force
official police wrist lock you can't hit
me try to hit me over here no try that
it's this hand
wrist lock boom too much pain you can't
even hit me try to hit me
if i had my gun you wouldn't try to hit
me though is the thing
oh cool cryptex can i have it no no you
can't where'd you get it how do you know
what a cryptex is i know what things are
well leslie hid the location of our
valentine's meeting place in here no
tried every five-letter word that has
anything to do with our third date
have you tried
it's a four-letter word
an s i really don't think it's that uh i
wish i could help you bro i don't know
if i can you're like the second smartest
guy i know
you should go to the first smartest guy
i know
[Applause]
hi ladies and gentlemen for the first
time ever in her new part-time job in
the public health department at city
halls and meredith perkins yay oh leslie
this is so nice i put poisonous gas in
one of these balloons so if any of them
pops you may die
no april we would all die
gases fill the volume of whatever
container they're in
school
hey uh babe it's me will you come down
here please and keep me company i'm so
bored i need you if i come down there
can i at least break something of course
babe anything you know that chris gave
me this great job as a weekend security
guard at city hall only one problem it's
a terrible job i did everything i was
supposed to do and i walked around the
building four times only 20 minutes has
gone by
huh i thought maybe 10 minutes had gone
by since i started talking it's only
been 15 seconds
oh
oh babe thank god you're here i got so
bored i started thinking about existence
do i matter do any of us
is there a master plan in the works a
grand design just dumb stuff like that
yeah who cares ah i thought being a
security guard would be exciting
nope ben
ben
yeah andy i think i might have found
something that's actually pretty cool
okay we'll just put it aside and i'll
read it later no andy found it and he's
gonna tell you about it right now go
babe uh it's the
redwood music program it's an
after-school music class for at-risk
kids it'll keep them off the street whoa
and the streets as you know are
dangerous
uh example i fell in a sewer grate once
i was there all day
in conclusion we cannot let our children
live in the sewer any longer redwood
music program go your honor amen hey ben
hi you wanted to talk to me or
probably not i mean i don't even want to
talk to me no i wanted to talk to you oh
i just wanted to thank you so much for
your help andy sorry we didn't wind up
choosing the after-school music programs
it's just i totally get it music program
would be effective but the ambulance is
going to help people right now who are
in trouble and probably look good in the
media
yeah that's
exactly right your morning tea mr wyatt
imagine all the money you could save if
you didn't have to pay for this
expensive stuff but right you could help
like a zillion more charities yeah
that's
also exactly right
i feel like i should have thought of
that well let me tell you something else
that's interesting ben what
i farted five minutes ago
didn't even smell it just now
that's how tight my pants are
anyhow later days dudes
i just need one more week and then i
think sorry could you please be careful
oh i am always careful
we're good if i could just get a little
bit more time i could figure out how to
fix this unfortunately i cannot give you
any more time what do you mean leslie i
am retiring at the end of this term so
i've been fine with you guys pushing me
around on this budget thing but if
you're ever gonna hold this job there's
something you need to understand city
council isn't about making everybody in
town happy in fact every decision you
make is going to make a lot of people
very unhappy
we play with live ammo around here
now i'm going to close the book on this
budget draft by the end of the business
day so if you can find some way out of
this mess by 5 p.m you let me know
thank you that's fair i did it
i got it out
oh geez you don't take the ship out here
you go
listen
tammy one was my sunday school teacher
too she can pinpoint your weaknesses and
then destroy you with just one word
and a jar of acid oh my god i think i
have an idea that could save ron andy
don't joke around i
have ideas too
ron swanson april ludgate hey i'm just
gonna pop over to grain and simple to
get the very best ingredients for my
burger do you want to come
what is grain and simple it's a health
food store pawnee doesn't have a health
food store no but snurling does and it's
only a 40 minute drive what are you
doing andy i'm getting healthier snacks
for the shoeshine stand chris is a food
genius
did you know that the food you eat
becomes energy yeah
boom that's spaghetti
nachos
the cookie
you